[Musique]
nouvelle candidature à l'élection
présidentielle celle de michèle alliot
marie qui a refusé de participer à la
primaire à droite par j'entendais une
radio ce matin et on va venir voir le
valls
on va voir ce qu'il a envie de vous dire
y avait même une dame qui disait il faut
qu'il sourie
je souris donc avec vous tous je
m'occupe de mon projet pour le pays du
projet qu'on veut porter pour le pays
au delà des clivages qui pour partie
sont artificiels ou des chicaya deux
clans qui ne m'intéresse pas une belle
casserole assumerait toujours évidemment
les réformes que nous avons engagées
mais aujourd'hui je ne suis plus premier
ministre
je suis candidat à la présidence de la
république
je suis libre peut pas parler de votre
bilan
parce que ça me déprimerait trop 1 n'est
pas fait que des se dit bon arrière
crisper une gêne récent blabla mais
manuel valls hockey ce soir vous allez
l'assumé totalement ce bilan j'adore une
seule primaire avec c'est à vous de les
convaincre
arrêtez tweets comme des gamins
de récré pourquoi le changement n'est
pas venu parce que l'état a été trop
faible avec les forts et trop dur avec
les faits par tous elle vous êtes vous
n'avez aucune chance comme on dit dans
mon pays il faut qu'on se pose donc
quand vous serez président de la
république il sera premier ministre
je vais réfléchir j'écrirai à jean luc
mélenchon et emmanuel macron pour leur
proposer de rejoindre la primaire les
mêmes qui aujourd'hui me demande d'aller
à cette primaire monsieur cambadélis par
exemple vous êtes un peureux dit il mais
il a raison si j'étais un peureux
j'aurais pas quitter le gouvernement
j'aurais pas décidé à l'époque on me
disait que j'étais fou prix je ne
désespère pas de le convaincre
et maintenant qu'en effet ce
rassemblement le progressiste que nous
avons construit commencent à leur faire
peur il faudrait qu'on aille se perdre
dans les chicaillas de la primaire du
parti socialiste
on dit que vous êtes derrière la
candidature de vincent peillon qui sait
ce qui se dit vous avez vous le savez je
suis ce que je suis chez vous je veux
démentir ce retrait n'est pas parce que
les approcher nathan est absolument il
abaisse la politique par la décision
vient de tomber
pour jérôme cahuzac cinq ans
d'inéligibilité
mais surtout trois ans de prison ferme
mais pas de commentaires à faire c'est
une décision de justice
cahuzac en mentant devant le parlement
sur le fait qu'il avait un compte en
suisse a commis une faute qui justifier
aux yeux de la justice une peine lourde
à des ti s'est passé je crois qu'on doit
s'interroger sur la relation qui était
celle du président de la république aux
français c'est sans doute injuste et
reproches qui lui sont faits et cette
relation était à ce point dégradée que
beaucoup ont ressenti ça comme une
délivrance
[Musique]